Hallo.
Ich bedanke mich für alle, für diese gelegenheit. Danke.
Okay.
Soll ich anfangen?
Ja bitte.
Ja.
Hallo, Sie sind mein Name.
Ich bin die Assistenz der Aufwärtssituation und für die
Genede das Aufwärtsgeschenk mit Ihnen führen, sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Äh, bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, würde ich Ihnen ein paar
allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Doris Röckemann.
Doris.
Doris, D-O-R-I-S.
E-O-R-I-S, Doris, ja.
Ja.
Und Röckemann schreibt sich R.
Ö.
Ja.
C-K.
E.
M.
N-N.
Wie der Mann.
Röckemann.
Okay.
Frau Röckemann.
Ja, Frau Röckemann.
Doris ist weiblich.
Okay.
Was ist die Sigena Geborun Frau Röckemann?
Am 3. Januar 1958.
Am 3. Januar.
1958.
Wie alt sind Sie?
64.
Frau Röckemann, könntest du mir bitte sagen, wie viel Sie wie
wie groß Sie sind?
Ich wiege 60 kg.
Und ich bin 1,66 m groß.
1,66 m groß.
So Frau Röckemann, was für Sie uns was können für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe Bauchschmerzen seit einem Tag.
Seit einem Tag.
Einem Tag, sie werden immer stärker.
Ähm.
Ja.
Können Sie mir bitte sagen, wo die Sigena ihr erschmerzen sind?
Ja, die begannen mehr so in der Mitte des Bauches und sind
jetzt ein bisschen mehr rechts, ein bisschen mehr rechts rüber so.
Und unter dem Rippenbogen etwas tiefer.
Am rechten Oberbau.
Ja, Oberbau, ein bisschen weiter unterhalb, vielleicht auch
Mittelbauch, ich weiß nicht, ich heiße das Mittelbau.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie sich mal langsam oder plöslich begonnen?
Die haben langsam begonnen.
Langsam, gestern, langsam begonnen.
Heute ungefähr einem Tag jetzt, seit 24 Stunden.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gehen Sie auf wieder weg?
Sie sind eigentlich immer da, aber dann kommt das manchmal,
wie so eine Welle, dass sie dann stärker wäre.
Sie sind wellenformig.
Sie sind etwas schwächer, aber Sie sind immer da.
Sie sind immer da.
Sind Sie krampfartig?
Ja, manchmal ist es so wie ein Krampf.
Und es wird eben immer schlimmer.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt auch zu Ihnen hier gekommen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay.
Können Sie mir bitte Ihre Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher stechend, drückend, pochend?
Wenn dann eher ein bisschen drückend, also pochend nicht.
Er drückend.
Wann treten die Schmerzen auf, zum Beispiel nach dem Essen oder
nach einer Bewegung?
Also ich habe jetzt seit gestern eigentlich nicht mehr gegessen,
weil ich keinen Appetit habe.
Ich habe nur immer ein bisschen etwas getrunken,
etwas Mineralwasser oder etwas Tee.
Aber mir ist auch etwas übel.
Also ich mag gerne etwas essen oder trinken.
Sie haben auch Übelkeit.
Haben Sie Erbrochen?
Nein, aber so, es ist so kurz davor.
Haben Sie auch Fieber?
Ein Fieber glaube ich nicht.
Nein, nicht.
Haben Sie volle Gefühle in Ihrem Magon?
Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck,
das drückt so etwas so hoch.
Ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass das sehr voll ist
im Bauch, aber ich habe nichts gegessen.
Sie haben nichts gegessen, aber Sie haben ein voller Gefühl.
Okay.
Wissen Sie oder haben Sie bemerkt, dass es eine bestimmte
Auslöser für diese Schmerzen gab?
Nein.
Haben Sie etwas ausprobiert, um die Schmerzen zu linden?
Ich habe etwas, eine Wärmflasche mal auf den Bauch gelegen.
Ja, das war nicht schlechter, aber auch nicht besser.
Das hat mir nicht viel geholfen.
Keine Verbesserung.
Aber auch keine Verschlimmerung.
Okay, gut.
Können Sie mir bitte sagen, wie ich das mal sagen kann,
sind auch eine Skala von 1 bis 2,
wobei 1 und 10 sehr stark Schmerzen sind.
Also, der Schmerz ist ja immer da, der ist bis zu 6,
aber wenn eine Welle kommt, dann ist es schon mindestens 8.
8.
Ja, wenn eine Schmerz Welle kommt.
Okay.
Wenn ich richtig verstanden habe,
Sie haben aber keine Schmerz mit der Lein genommen.
Nein, bis jetzt nicht.
Ich nehme ganz selten Schmerzmittel.
Aber ich habe gehört, man soll jetzt keine Schmerzmittel nehmen.
Wenn man Bauchschmerzen hat, dann ist das nicht so gut.
Okay, können Sie jetzt gerade
ihr Rechimarsen aushalten, bis unser Gespräch zu Ende ist?
Oder soll ich Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel geben?
Nein, das geht noch.
Wenn Sie, wenn ich später bekomme, jetzt geht das noch. Danke.
Okay, das ist besser.
Aber Sie können mir ein Zeichen geben und keine
Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel geben, weil Sie nicht hartrahmen können.
Okay.
Oh, wie sieht es aus mit Ihrem Stuhlgang und Wassalasse?
Oh, Stuhlgang.
Stuhlgang habe ich jetzt
das letzte Mal, glaube ich, vor 2 Tagen gehabt.
Haben Sie immer verstockt oder?
Nee, in letzter Zeit war das mit dem Stuhlgang etwas schwieriger.
Sonst war das immer gut.
Aber in letzter Zeit war es eher manchmal nur alle 2 Tage.
Oder dann war der Stuhlgang so ganz klein.
Das war nicht so gut.
Normal ist das besser.
Können Sie mir sagen, seit wann es so ist?
Seit 2-3 Wochen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wassalasse?
Nein.
Nein, das ist in Ordnung.
Das war immer schon in Ordnung, ob ich nie Probleme gehabt habe.
Okay.
Hat die Farbe Ihres Stuhls verändert, hat sich verändert?
Oder ist das normal?
Wie ist es?
Von der Farbe her ist es eher normal.
Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, es ist etwas mehr Schleim in Stuhl.
Das ist Schleim.
Ja, haben Sie auch außerhalb von Sortbrennen,
wie Sie haben, Sortbrennen oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, normal vertrage ich alles.
Aber wie gesagt, in letzter Zeit ist das mit dem Appetit auch nicht ganz so gut,
habe ich den Eindruck.
Seit 2-3 Wochen ist das auch.
Appetit.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit abgenommen oder zugenommen?
Ja, ich habe gestern noch mich nochmal gewogen
und da habe ich so innerhalb jetzt, ich wiege mich nicht oft,
aber ich glaube, ich habe so 4-5 kg, habe ich Gewicht verloren.
Hier.
Können Sie mir sagen, über welcherseits Raum?
Wie viele?
2 Monate?
2 Monate.
Okay.
Ja.
Frau Rückkemann,
lassen Sie uns bitte über Ihre Vorerkrankungen besprechen.
Leider Sie auch an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Was meinen Sie unter chronischen Erkrankungen?
Was verstehen Sie darunter?
Ja, wie Bluthochdruck, Superkrankheit.
Ja, Bluthochdruck.
Da muss ich auch ein Medikament einnehmen.
Seit wann?
Seit knapp 10 Jahren.
Ich würde sagen seit 8 Jahren.
Okay.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich nehme gegen Bluthochdruck nur ein Mittel ein.
Ich muss das gerade sehen auf dem Zettel, das heißt,
Rami-Pril.
5 Milligramm.
5 Milligramm, ja.
Ich muss eine Tablette morgens nehmen und eine Tablette abends.
Aber Sie haben noch andere Medikamente.
Nein, nur das Bluthochdruck.
Nur Bluthochdruck.
Sie nehmen auch keine Schmerz, Respektarfe beim Bedarf.
Okay.
Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja.
Als Kind.
Mir der Blinde haben operiert.
Gründer operiert.
Da war ich ungefähr 10 Jahre alt.
Und ich wurde schon mal an der Galle operiert.
Das war ungefähr vor 15 Jahren wegen Gallensteinen.
wurde in einer Galamblase entfernt?
Ja.
Aber seitdem habe ich da keine Probleme mehr.
Gut.
Hätten Sie weitere Operationen?
Nein.
Nein? Okay.
Würden Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt im Krankenhaus?
Was wurde ich behandelt?
Stationär.
Stationär im Krankenhaus?
Ja.
Nur bei den Operationen?
Bei der Blindam-Operation und bei der Gallen-Operation.
Aber sonst war ich noch nie im Krankenhaus.
Okay.
Sind alle diese Operationen Komplikationslosfer laufen?
Ja.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Rükemann.
Sind bei Ihnen allergienbekannt?
Allergien.
Mein Mann sagt, ich hätte vielleicht etwas heuschnupfen.
Heuschnupfen.
Also im April, Mai muss ich häufiger genießen.
Aber ich finde das nicht schlimm.
Vielleicht habe ich etwas heuschnupfen.
Aber mich stört das nicht.
Sie können vertragen.
Sind Sie sonst andere Unverzüglichkeiten gegen Lebensmittel?
Nein.
Ich kann sonst alles essen.
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Geimpft?
Ja.
Ich habe jetzt auch gerade die Corona-Impfung die 4. Bekannung.
Und habe sonst die 14.
Und mein Hausarzt sagt, ich habe alle Impfungen, die notwendig sind.
Ich habe aber jetzt meinen Impfpass nicht mit.
Ich kann das jetzt nicht zeigen.
Aber Corona-Geimpf bin ich 4-mal.
4-mal, okay.
Jetzt benötige ich ein paar Informationen über Ihre Gewohnheit.
Frau Rükemann, trauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Sie trauchen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber auch nur wenig.
Ich trinke mal ein Schluck Bier oder ein Wein.
Aber das ist nicht jeden Tag.
Vielleicht am Wochenende mal.
Aber das ist alles sehr wenig.
An wo hin?
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht per Säune.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Nein.
Okay.
Frau Rükemann, wie ist Ihre Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Ich lebe mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, drei Kinder.
36 Jahre alt.
Ja, sind Sie wie gesund?
Die jüngste, die Tochter,
die 30 Jahre alt hat.
Ich habe eine Schildrüse unter Funktionen.
Aber es ist jetzt behandelt und es geht ihr gut.
Das ist schon medikamentös eingestellt.
Ja, sie nimmt jeden Morgen eine Tablette.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin jetzt Rentnerin.
Ich war bis vor einem halben Jahr, war ich Busfahrerin.
Ich habe hier in der Stadt einen Linienbus gefahren.
Frau Rükemann, gibt es eine
eine wichtige Krankheit, die ich von der Familie wissen sollte?
Mein Vater ist mit 78 Jahren verstorben.
An einem Herzinfarkt.
Und die Mutter hatte sie mit 60 Jahren Darmkrebs.
Und ist operiert worden.
Aber die Mutter lebt.
Die Mutter ist jetzt 90 Jahre alt.
Hat sie Darmkrebs?
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie gesagt?
Ich war meine Mutter 60 Jahre alt.
30 Jahre war das.
Darmkrebs.
Es wurde aber gut behandelt.
Sie wurde operiert und sie waren alle gut.
Sie lebt jetzt ja.
Sie ist ja 90 Jahre alt geworden.
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Er ist ähre jünger als ich.
Er hat auch etwas hohen Blutdruck.
Aber sonst fühlt es ihm ganz gut.
Ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Was habe ich?
Was sind das für Bauchschmerzen?
Frau Rükemann, ich werde Sie,
das kann ich momentan genau Ihnen nicht sagen, was Sie haben.
Aber ich werde Sie so erst körperlich untersuchen
und Ihnen Blutabnahmen,
und wir würden zusammen ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Sobald alle Befunde vorlegen,
komme ich zu Ihnen.
Und wir können weiter besprechen über Ihre Diagnose.
Kann ich etwas weiter trinken?
Oder wenn ich etwas Hunger habe, kann ich etwas essen?
Es wäre gut, wenn Sie nicht essen.
Sie können ein, zwei Schokolade Wasser trinken.
Aber nicht viel.
Danke.
Wir machen fünf Minuten.
Brauchen Sie fünf Minuten?
Oder sind Sie schon fertig?
Zwei, drei Minuten.
Ich kann die Patientin vorstellen.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe gerade eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Darf ich die Patientin vorstellen?
Ja, bitte.
Danke.
Doris Ruckermann ist eine Patientin.
Sie ist seit einem Tag
bestehenden Probedienten
in rechten Oberbau
lokalisierten.
Bauchsmarsen.
Stärke und wählenformige Bauchsmarsen.
Sie sind seit einem Tag bestehenden Probedienten.
Sie haben die Patientin
berichtet, dass die Schmerzen
kraftfaltig und drückend sind.
Sie bewertet die Schmerzen
mit sechs, wenn sie keine Schmerzen
hat.
Sie haben sie mit acht, wenn sie
eine Schmerz haben.
Sie haben sie mit acht, wenn sie eine Schmerz haben.
Im Punktum-Maximum der Welle bis acht.
Wie alt ist die Patientin?
Die Patientin ist 64 Jahre alt.
Ja, wir haben ja das.
Es gibt auch Fälligkeiten in der Vorgeschichte
bei der Patientin?
Als Vorerkrankungen hat die Patientin, leidet die Patientin an arteriale Hipartoni,
ja sie hat eine Akkondektumie für zehn Jahre und für fünf Jahre eine Polycystektumie.
Die Operationen sind kompliziert.
Vor zehn Jahren oder mit zehn Jahren? Im Alter von zehn Jahren?
Ja, im Alter von zehn Jahren.
Ich habe es nicht gesagt, aber ich habe es gesagt.
Ja, als Vorerkrankungen.
Sie nimmt Arteriale Hipartoni, Renepil 5 mg, 2 mal Amtak 1.
Anzusten hat ja keine Konni-Schar-Krankungen.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten jetzt in der aktuellen Anamnese?
Seit zwei, drei Wochen hat ihre Stuhlgewohnheiten sich verändert.
Sie erwähnt von Verstopfung.
Die Patientin hat mitgezählt, dass ihr Zugang dünner geworden ist.
Bis Blut im Stuhl? Hat sie Blut im Stuhl bemerkt?
Ich habe leider nicht gefragt, aber sie hat nicht gesagt, dass sie Blut schlug.
Ich habe aber die Farbe gefragt. Sie hat mir geantwortet, dass keine Veränderung weiterfahl, weiter Farbe gab.
Hatte die Patientin schon eine Vorsorgekuliskopie?
Sie hat nicht erwähnt.
Aber sie haben auch nicht gefragt?
Ich habe auch nicht gefragt.
Ich muss fragen, weil in der Familiengeschichte die Mutter Darmkrebs hat.
In welchem Alter hatte die Mutter Darmkrebs?
Mit 60 Jahren.
Sie wurde operiert.
Hat die Patientin eine positive Familie?
Die Patientin hat eine positive Familie.
Was macht ihr Körpergewicht?
Ihre Körpergewicht hat die Patientin in den letzten zwei Monaten 4-5 kg abgenommen.
Sie hat schon einiges.
In welchem Zustand ist die Patientin?
Ist sie dehydriert?
Sie musste dehydriert sein.
Sie hat uns mitgezahlt, dass sie mitgegessen hat.
Sie hat auch gesagt, dass sie etwas getrunken hat.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Anhand an amästischen Angaben vermute ich bei der Patientin
eine Bankreskarcinom oder eine Darmkrebs.
Eine Kolonkarcinom oder eine Bankreskarcinom?
Ja, eine Bankreskarcinom mit der Metastasierung von Kolon.
Die Patientin hat verdünnete Stuhlgang.
Die Patientin hat Oberbauchschmerzen.
Das weist auf einem Schicht im Oberbauch.
Sie sagten, dass die Patientin operiert.
Sie ist appendectomiert und Cholizistectomiert.
Bankres kann auch der Wellenförmige Schmerz versprechen.
Was spricht für Kolonkarcinom oder ein Subilius?
Gewitzabnahme und Verstopfung.
Seit vor drei Wochen aufgetretenen Verstopfung.
Die Patientin hat Schleimauflagerungen auf dem Stuhl.
Ich glaube, wie Sie das schildern, muss man beides untersuchen.
Ich tippe eher auf Kolonkarcinom.
Ich bin das, haben Sie gut dargestellt.
Es war ein Missverständnis.
Ich habe als Patientin gesagt, die Schmerzen waren im Anfang in der Mitte.
Und sind dann rechts mehr in den Bauch gegangen.
Aber mehr Mittelbauch.
Nicht so sehr Oberbauch.
Das war ein Missverständnis.
Mehr den Mittelbauch.
Bankreskarcinom kann natürlich sein.
Manchmal ist Bankres auch im Rücken.
Aber nicht klassisch.
Ich glaube, die Patientin sollte einen Kolonkarcinom machen.
Meine Kritik oder meine Anmerkung war,
Sie haben früh gefragt, ob die Patientin Schmerzen hat.
Ob sie etwas gegen die Schmerzen braucht.
Nein, hat die Patientin gesagt, nein.
Ich finde es durchaus wichtig,
wenn man merkt, die Patientin ist etwas dehydriert.
Kann ja sein.
Das man jetzt sagt.
Frau Röckemann, ich sie jetzt hier befrage,
mache ich Ihnen schon eine Infusion.
Dass Sie einen Zugang legen.
Kurz Blutdruck,
können Sie eine Infusion dranlegen.
Oder über den Zugang können Sie auch schon Blut abnehmen.
Dann haben Sie alle Handlungsmöglichkeiten.
Und Sie kümmern sich um die Patientin.
Die Patientin hat den Eindruck, jetzt wird mir hier geholfen.
Meine Schmerzen werden ernst genommen.
Das hat sich gut gefragt mit den Schmerzen.
Wenn die Schmerzen stärker werden, können Sie etwas bekommen.
Wichtig, ich habe es gefragt,
kann ich etwas trinken?
Oder vielleicht etwas essen, wenn ich Hunger habe.
Da würde ich sehr streng sein.
Ich hänge Ihnen eine Infusion an.
Und kommen Sie flüssig.
Sie bekommen auch etwas Kalorien über die Infusion.
Dann brauchen Sie nichts mehr zu essen.
Sie sollten nichts mehr oral zu sich nehmen.
Wir wissen genau, was kommt.
Wenn ein Ilios da ist,
der vielleicht notfallmäßig operiert werden muss,
ist es sinnvoll, die Patientin zu machen.
Was würden Sie erwarten?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung des Bauchers?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung erwarte ich
einen Darmen,
einen Durukdolente.
Ich habe einen Durukdolente.
Von Euch.
Bei der Pelpation ein Messes.
Ja.
der Auskultation.
Bei der Auskultation
kann ich hören ganze Darngeräusche.
Träge nicht sehr trällig Darngeräusche,
wie man manchmal klingende Darngeräusche
coppert mit Flüssigkeit durch hammer spiritually,
oder ganz trägedanke Geräusche.
Wichtig ist noch, falls Sie das gefragt würden,
zu sagen, haben Sie Rektal untersucht?
Dann kann man sagen, Rektal, die Ampulle ist leer,
kein Stuhl in der Ampulle,
spricht auch dafür, dass von oben nicht mehr nachkommt,
dass der Darm zu ist.
wäre vielleicht noch ganz wichtig,
falls so etwas in einer Prüfung auch mal kommt,
dass Sie sagen,
was erwarten Sie dann für ein Untersuchungsergebnis?
Um Ilios zu auszusehen.
Aber der Verdacht auf ein Ilios besteht natürlich bei dieser Klinik.
Der Schmerz ist wellenförmig, der Patientin ist übel,
sie ist kurz vor dem Erbrechen.
Der Stuhl war in den letzten Wochen verändert gegenüber früher
und sie hat eine Gewichtsabnahme.
Sie hat vermehrt Schleim im Stuhl berichtet.
Das muss ja auch nicht unbedingt Blut sein.
Zumindest kein sichtbares Blut.
Körperliche Untersuchung, Infusion anhängen, Labor
und vielleicht orientierend
zumindest versuchen, ein Ultraschall zu machen.
Wie Sie das auch oft sehen,
das ist ja auch nicht so wichtig,
es gibt ja auch viele ja wenig,
weil so viel Luft im Bauch ist.
Aber wichtig wäre ja zu schauen,
gibt es freie Flüssigkeit im Bauch.
Wie sieht vielleicht Pankrias aus?
Oder kann ich am Darm sehen,
dass der Darm sehr weit ist
und da unter ist es eher dünn.
Aber das ist eben Ultraschall ja auch nicht immer gut zu sehen.
Aber ich finde, Sie haben das sehr ruhig und systematisch gemacht,
und für mich ist es immer wieder wichtig,
machen Sie nicht zu viele komplizierte Sätze.
Lieber sagen Frau Röckemann ist 66 Jahre alt
und stellt sich vor, mit Schmerzen seit 24 Stunden
im Bauch, die in der Mitte begannen
und dann mehr nach rechts gezogen sind.
Die Schmerzen sind wellenförmig
und auf einer VAS-Skala zwischen 6 und 8
oder undulierende Schmerzen,
wenn wir jetzt Fachbegriffe bringen wollen.
Aber Fachbegriffe haben Sie sehr gut eingesetzt.
Ich fand ich gut, das müssen Sie ja möglichst
in der Vorstellung beim Oberarzt.
Und gegenüber der Patientin Frau Röckemann
haben Sie eine verständliche Sprache gewählt.
Auch das ist wichtig,
dass der Patient sich nicht versteht.
Ja, ich fand das gut.
Wann haben Sie Prüfung?
Am 1. April.
Ja, ich hoffe.
Ich will noch etwas trainieren,
aber ich habe da ein gutes Gefühl.
Ah, danke.
Ja, ich hoffe, vielen Dank.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg.